l'ordre du jour appelle l'examen des
conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire chargée d'élaborer un texte
sur les dispositions restant en
discussion de la proposition de loi pour
renforcer la prévention en santé au
travail
dans la discussion générale la parole
est à madame la présidente pascale gruny
rapporteur pour le sénat de la
commission mixte paritaire pour cinq
minutes homme monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
la commission mixte paritaire est
parvenu hier un texte commun sur la
proposition de loi pour renforcer la
prévention en santé au travail
cet accord qui est le fruit d' échanges
nourris avec nos collègues députés
charlotte parmentier le coq et carole
grandjean auteurs du texte et rapporteur
pour l'assemblée nationale répond
globalement aux attentes et aux
préoccupations exprimées par le sénat il
devrait nous conduire à adopter une
dernière fois en ce qui concerne cette
proposition de loi
le renforcement de la démarche
d'évaluation et de prévention des
risques professionnels au sein des
entreprises est un objectif que nous
partageons tous nous avons cependant
tenu à l'aborder avec pragmatisme en
garissa en garantissant notamment le
caractère opérationnel de l'élaboration
et de la conservation du document unique
d'évaluation des risques professionnels
le déut le rp je me félicite en
particulier que l'obligation de dépôt
dématérialisée du des huées
introduite par le sénat l'article 2 soit
maintenu dans le texte de la cmp sa mise
en oeuvre sera bien entendu échelonnées
dans le temps pour tenir compte de la
taille des entreprises et de leurs
contraintes et nous confions le soin aux
organisations patronales de définir les
modalités du déploiement du portail
numérique qui centralisera ce dépôt
dématérialisée nous partagions par
ailleurs ac et rapporteur de l'assemblée
nationale le souci d'améliorer la
qualité des prestations des services de
prévention et de santé au travail
interentreprises les sps délit
et leur mobilisation dans l'ensemble de
leurs missions dans une logique de
service rendu aux entreprises adhérentes
et à leurs salariés à l'article 8 qui
contient plusieurs avancées concernant
le cadre d'exercices des sps dei la
rédaction finale reprend plusieurs
rapports du sénat
la précision apportée à la définissent
définition de l'ensemble socle de
services
l'initiative donner aux partenaires
sociaux à travers la proposition du
comité national de prévention et de
santé au travail
le cnp est et dans l'élaboration du
cahier des charges de la nouvelle
procédure de certification
enfin la production d'un régime
d'administration provisoire permettant
de remédier à une situation du
dysfonctionnement grave d'un espèce pays
qui l'empêcherait d'assurer ses missions
nous avons également défendu
l'application à l'ensemble des espèces
dei à l'article 13 d'une obligation de
mise en conformité de leur système
d'information et de leurs outils
numériques à des référentiels
l'interopérabilité et de sécurité
concernant la tarification de ses
services le sénat a introduit à
l'article 9 de modifications importantes
d'une part l'encadrement du montant des
cotisations dans un tunnel défini par
référence au coût moyen national de
l'offre socle
d'autre part le calcul des cotisations
en fonction du nombre de personnes
suivies non proratisé en équivalent
temps plein ces dispositions qui
traduisent les ambitions de l'accord
national interprofessionnel ani du 9
décembre dernier
en matière de transparence financière
dsp ce délit et permettent d'assurer une
meilleure équité entre les entreprises
sont reprises dans leur rédaction issue
du sénat en matière de suivi
d'accompagnement des travailleurs
vulnérables
le sénat avait veillé à poursuivre avec
un souci d'efficacité d'opérationnalité
l'objectif d'améliorer les outils de
maintien dans l'emploi des personnes
malades ou handicapées
le texte de la cmp reprend certaines des
améliorations apportées par le sénat au
dispositif de la cellule de prévention
de la désinsertion professionnelle qui
doit être créé dans chaque espèce et la
possibilité de mutualiser la cellule
ainsi que la fixation dans le contrat
pluriannuel d'objectifs et de moyens
d'exigences minimales sur sa composition
s'agissant à l'article 18 du rendez-vous
de liaison qui peut être organisé en
train travailleurs en arrêt de travail
de longue durée et son employeur nous
avons abouti à une rédaction
intermédiaires qui rétablit la
participation du spt à ce rendez vous
ainsi que l'avait prévu l'assemblée
nationale mais maintient la possibilité
introduite par le sénat que l'employeur
le sollicite en matière de suivi de
certains publics particuliers plusieurs
rapports du sénat figure dans le texte
de la cmp
l'expérimentation d'actions de
prévention collective destinée aux
salariés intérimaires à l'article 17 bis
à les modalités de mise en oeuvre du
suivi de l'état de santé des salariés du
particulier employeur à l'article 17 ter
ainsi que la possibilité donnée aux
chefs d'entreprises de bénéficier des
services du sps pays auquel son
entreprise est affiliée à l'article 17
cas je me félicite enfin que nous ayons
obtenue à l'article 27 le remplacement
d'une habilitation à légiférer par
ordonnances afin de fusionner l'anact et
les arabes par des dispositions
inscrites directement dans la loi je
vous invite donc aujourd'hui au nom de
la commission mixte paritaire a adopté
cette proposition de loi et je vous
remercie
merci mme amara porter la parole est à
monsieur stéphane artano rapporteur pour
le sénat de la commission mixte
paritaire pour cinq minutes
monsieur le président madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues je me réjouis à mon tour
que la commission mixte paritaire soit
parvenu à un accord sur les dispositions
restant en discussion de la proposition
de loi pour renforcer la prévention en
santé au travail cet accord conclut des
échanges fructueux entre l'assemblée
nationale et le sénat pour l'élaboration
d'un texte qui vous est soumis
aujourd'hui il concrétise une démarche
inédite de démocratie sociale et
parlementaires au service de la
protection de la santé des travailleurs
il me semble que la commission mixte
paritaire est parvenu un texte équilibré
qui retient d'importants apports du
sénat nous avons veillé à réunir les
conditions d'une médecine du travail
moderne au service de la prévention est
adapté aux nouveaux défis posés par
l'évolution des technologies et des
modes d'organisation du travail
nous sommes accordés avec nos collègues
députés mais sur le fait que
l'évaluation des risques professionnels
ne devait pas être perçu comme une
contrainte administrative subis par les
entreprises
au contraire les employeurs doivent
saisir l'occasion de cette évaluation
qui engagent leur responsabilité pour
répondre à leur obligation de sécurité à
l'égard de leurs salariés pour sa
diffusion effective dans l'ensemble des
entreprises et sa déclinaison en actions
de prévention concrètes
cette évaluation doit être adaptée à la
réalité du fonctionnement des
entreprises
c'est pourquoi le texte issu des travaux
de la cmp reprend à l'article 2 les
apports du sénat visant à adapter les
modalités de définition du plan d'action
de prévention afin que celles ci soient
proportionnées aux enjeux et aux moyens
internes des entreprises notamment les
tpe et pme de moins de 50 salariés
avec ma collègue rapporteur pascale
gruny nous avons au plaider pour le
décloisonnement de la médecine du
travail et de la santé publique
nécessité que nous avions identifiés dès
la rédaction de notre rapport
d'information sur la santé au travail
d'octobre 2010 9 6 pourquoi le
renforcement à l'article de terre du
suivi post exposition des travailleurs
exposés à des risques particuliers ainsi
que l'approfondissement de la
coopération entre médecine du travail et
médecine de ville constitue à mon sens
des avancées significatives qui ont été
approuvés par l'acm
cette coopération renforcée doit se
traduire par un meilleur partage
d'informations entre professionnels de
santé dans un objectif de prévention et
de coordination des parcours que ce soit
au travers du dossier médical partagé du
dossier médical en santé au travail ou
du recours aux consultations à distance
des cloisonnements ne veut pas dire pour
autant uniformisation par sa
connaissance fine des entreprises la
médecine travail reste la mieux placée
pour assurer le suivi médical des
travailleurs nous avons ainsi des fondus
avec un collègue pascale gruny la
spécificité de la médecine du travail
dont l'attractivité doit être
considérablement renforcé
d'expérimentation introduite par le
sénat à l'article 21 bis permettant
d'étendre le droit de prescription des
médecins du travail à trois régions a
dit expérimental constitue un premier
pas en ce sens de nombreux efforts
restent à mener pour attirer davantage
les étudiants en médecine vers cette
spécialité
j'invite à cet égard le gouvernement à
revoir les conditions de stage des
externes en médecine pour leur permettre
de se familiariser aux enjeux de la
médecine du travail
il aurait alors une meilleure
appréhension de ces sujets lors de leur
choix de spécialités pour l'internât un
médecin généraliste ne pourra pas
remplacer médecin du travail
d'autant que les difficultés de
démographie médicale touche
particulièrement ces deux spécialités
dans ce contexte nous considérons que le
dispositif de médecins praticiens
correspondant constitue un moyen de
susciter des vocations chez des médecins
généralistes qui seraient tentés en
milieu de carrière par exemple par un
exercice salariés en médecine du travail
même s'il ne résoudra pas à lui seul les
tensions démographique que connaissent
les services de santé au travail
en outre la montée en compétence pique
nique des infirmiers en santé au travail
est une piste prometteuse
ces professionnels vont prendre une
place croissante dont le suivi de la
santé des travailleurs et la qualité de
leur formation de théâtre est garanti
enfin sur la question plus féerique mais
non moins importante de la définition du
harcèlement sexuel au travail
à l'article 1er le texte de la cmp
et conserve moyennant un ajustement
purement rédactionnelles la modification
apportée par senna l'initiative de nos
collègues laurence cohen et laurence
rossignol qui vise à centrer cette
définition sur les faits subis par la
victime et non sur l'intention de
l'agresseur c'est donc un texte
équilibré répondant à un objectif d'une
meilleure prévention santé au travail de
l'ensemble des travailleurs et intégrant
d apport significatif du sénat que nous
proposons d'adopter
je vous en remercie merci c'est le
rapporteur la parole est à mme
st-laurent pietra skis secrétaire d'état
chargé les retraites et de la santé au
travail
monsieur le président madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales madame et monsieur le
rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
suis heureux de prendre la parole devant
vous à l'occasion de ces conclusions de
la commission mixte paritaire sur la
proposition de loi pour renforcer la
prévention de la santé au travail
elle marque vous le savez l'arrivée au
terme de l'examen de ce texte
d'initiative parlementaire fight est
d'ailleurs rappelé tout à l'heure par
madame la sénatrice pascale gruny ce
texte d'initiative parlementaire pour
lequel le gouvernement au final se
réjouit que le parlement ait pu parvenir
à un accord conclusif et constructif je
tiens à cet égard à remercier tout
particulièrement votre président de la
commission des affaires sociales
catherine de roche voudra porter pascale
gruny stéphane artano ainsi que
l'ensemble des membres de la commission
mixte paritaire dans les deux assemblées
votre travail de grande qualité permet
d'aboutir aujourd'hui à un texte solide
et équilibré qui conformément à
l'engagement du gouvernement vient
donner une réalité législatives et
démocratique à l'accord national un
terme en conclus entre les partenaires
sociaux en décembre dernier je me
félicite de cette complémentarité liant
à la vitalité de notre dialogue social
celle de notre démocratie représentative
dans l'intérêt et au final pour le
bénéfice de la santé des millions de
salariés et de leurs employeurs la crise
sanitaire que nous continuons de
traverser et nous rappellent chaque jour
l'enjeu essentiel qu'est l'amélioration
de la santé au travail en jeu pour
lequel le gouvernement est pleinement
mobilisée c'est également une attente
forte des salariés les entreprises que
j'ai pu mesurer à travers mes nombreux
déplacements depuis plus d'un an
à leurs côtés au sein des services de
santé au travail
l'abs et messieurs les sénateurs je vous
le disais cette proposition de loi
contient de très belles avancées que le
gouvernement soutient alors je ne
rentrerai pas ici dans le détail sur
chacune des dispositions mais
jean résumerait brièvement d'esprit si
vous le permettez la teneur je souhaite
commencer par ce biais le compromis
trouvé concernant le document unique
d'évaluation des risques professionnels
sénateurs artano l'a évoqué tout à
l'heure à l'article 2 dont sa rédaction
sénat qui créait pour les entreprises
les obligations proportionnée à leur
taille et à leurs moyens notamment qui
concerne les entreprises de moins de 50
salariés
le dépôt des documents uniques et leur
conservation sur un portail numérique
géré par les organisations
professionnelles est aussi une avancée
importante pour sécuriser l'accès à
l'information et donc les droits des
salariés
je me souviens d'ailleurs que ce sujet
avait été abordé
très tôt dans la discussion lors de mon
audition par votre commission des
affaires sociales par les deux
rapporteurs
de même le gouvernement se félicite de
l'accord trouvé entre les deux
assemblées sur l'accès au dossier
médical partagé dossier médical en santé
au travail
je pense aussi aux ajustements qui ont
été apportées sur le rendez-vous liaison
qui permettront de renforcer
l'efficacité de ce dispositif destiné à
anticiper et préparer la reprise
d'activité du salarié à la définition
d'un cadre pour la santé au travail des
salariés des particuliers employeurs et
les assistants maternels qui permettra
de mettre en place dans le cadre du
dialogue social de branche la prise en
charge effective de ces publics
le gouvernement se réjouit aussi tout
particulièrement des avancées en matière
de lutte contre le harcèlement sexuel ça
a été rappelé tout à leur fruit du
travail conjoint entre vos deux
assemblées et des échanges nourris qui
ont eu lieu ici avec deux sénatrices
dont vous avez rappelé tout à l'heure
l'engagement sur le sujet monsieur le
sénateur artano et la meuse et messieurs
les sénateurs pour conclure et comme
j'ai eu l'occasion de le rappeler le
retour d'expérience de la crise du coc
u19 vont nous permettre de construire
ensemble un modèle de santé au travail
plus proche de l'entreprise et des
salariés et plus orientée vers
l'accompagnement et le conseil pour la
mise en place de mesures de prévention
collectif
il est en effet essentiel de moderniser
trois systèmes de santé au travail afin
de l'adapter de répondre aux enjeux des
parcours professionnels que nous vivons
aujourd'hui dans notre xxième siècle le
gouvernement est prêt l'ensemble des
acteurs y est prêt c'est donc pour cette
raison dans ce même esprit de consensus
qui nous anime et tout au long du débat
parlementaire que je vous invite à
suivre les conclusions de la commission
mixte paritaire et à voter la
proposition de loi pour renforcer la
prévention en santé au travail qui vous
est soumise aujourd'hui j'ai fourni un
monsieur le ministre
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à monsieur lévriers pour
le groupe air des pays pour quatre
minutes aux faits scientifiques
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales madame et monsieur
lire à porter mes chers collègues
renforcer la prévention au sein des
entreprises et décloisonner la santé
publique et la santé au travail
améliorer la qualité du service rendu
par les sp est et renforcer
l'accompagnement de certains publics
notamment vulnérables et lutter contre
la désinsertion professionnelle ou
encore réorganisées la gouvernance de la
santé au travail que celle ci soit
interne ou s p est et où concerne le
pilotage national et territorial de
celle ci voici les quatre grands axes de
ce texte fruit d'un long processus de
démocratie sociale et parlementaires mes
chers collègues
notre mission était de veiller à ce que
la transcription de l'accord national
interprofessionnel du 9 décembre dernier
dans la loi respecte aussi bien son
contenu que son équilibre aussi je me
réjouis que la commission mixte
paritaire et trouvé hier un accord sur
les dispositions restant en discussion
de la proposition de loi visant à
renforcer la prévention en santé au
travail initié par mesdames les députés
la reine charlotte parmentier le coq et
carole grandjean les travaux issus de
l'examen du sénat ne remettant pas en
cause la philosophie même du texte une
cmp conclusive était souhaitée par
l'ensemble des rapporteurs et
rapporteuse et c'est dans ce sens que
les modifications ont été apportées
je pense notamment à l'adaptation pour
les entreprises de moins de 50 salariés
des actions de prévention et de
protection découlant du document unique
d'évaluation et de prévention des
risques professionnels en gardant la
possibilité de réaliser une consultation
à distance sans pour autant utiliser le
terme de téléconsultation inadéquate ou
encore en donnant la possibilité aux
médecins du travail de ne pas être
l'unique animateur et coordinateur de la
cellule pluridisciplinaire de prévention
de la désinsertion professionnelle
la cmp a tenu compte des modifications
que nous avions porté en séance le texte
définitif retient également
l'expérimentation d'actions de
prévention collective
destiné aux salariés intérimaires et la
possibilité pour un chef d'entreprise de
bénéficier du suivi médical assuré par
le service de prévention et de santé au
travail
enfin nous sommes satisfaits que
plusieurs des modifications que nous
avions porté en séance était et
conservés tels que permettre la
mutualisation des services de santé au
travail pour les travailleurs ayant est
une pluralité d'employeurs à l'article
17 bis ou encore les précisions
concernant les infirmières de santé au
travail exerçant leur mission au sein du
service de santé des gens de mer à
l'article 23
une fois de plus nous pouvons nous
féliciter d'un bicamérisme équilibré où
chaque chambre a pu faire valoir son
point de vue afin d'enrichir le texte de
manière constructive
bien évidemment compte tenu de
l'importance de ce texte et de la
construction du compromis positif
réalisé entre sénat et assemblée
nationale
nous ferons les conclusions de la
commission mixte paritaire merci chers
collègues dans la suite de la discussion
la parole est à madame apourceau poly
pour le groupe crc e pour 4 minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
la commission mixte paritaire sur la
proposition de loi visant à renforcer la
prévention en santé au travail
un réussi à se mettre d'accord hier
après midi sur un texte il faut bien sûr
le dire au rabais alors que les
organisations syndicales et les
associations plaidé en faveur d'une loi
qu'ils fassent de la prévention des
risques professionnels
une priorité qui garantisse un accès
rapide et de qualité au service de santé
au travail et qui favorise le maintien
dans l'emploi des salariés vulnérables
le compte n'y est pas bien au contraire
le texte renvoie la responsabilité de la
santé et de la sécurité sur chaque
salarié avec la création du passeport
prévention la proposition de loi remet
en cause la visite de pré-reprise en
court circuitant le médecin du travail
avec les fameux rendez-vous de liaison
le gouvernement tente d'effacer le lien
de subordination entre les salariés et
l'employeur seuls les médecins du
travail ont la formation et
l'indépendance pour connaître des
raisons personnelles et médical qui
conduisent les salariés a arrêté de
travailler
alors que l'accès à la médecine du
travail demeure toujours aussi compliqué
sur les territoires le gouvernement
préfère créer des médecins praticiens
correspondants et déléguer les fonctions
aux infirmières et infirmiers plutôt que
de revaloriser des métiers augmenter les
salaires
l'expérimentation du droit de
prescription des médecins du travail est
une revendication des praticiens c'est
une avancée mais ce n'est pas suffisant
pour créer une dynamique sur une filière
délaissé depuis des années la commission
mixte paritaire a conservé la
proposition du sénat de créer un portail
numérique pour archiver le document
unique d'évaluation des risques
nous étions intervenus contre cet
archivage géré par les seules
organisations patronales sans aucune
garantie de sécurité pour les données de
santé numériser la trace
habilités des expositions aux risques
professionnels doit relever d'un
organisme public indépendant comme les
carsat où les directs
la seule modification positive concerne
l'adoption de l'amendement du groupe crc
eux portés par ma collègue laurence
cohen qui revenait sur la définition
pénale du harcèlement les organisations
féministes nous avait interpellés pour
maintenir une définition du harcèlement
qui permettent aux victimes d'obtenir
réparation aux prud'hommes
indistinctement de la pressée de la
procédure devant la juridiction pénale
concernant la majorité des
problématiques de santé au travail
les questions demeurent sans réponse les
salariés devront donc encore patienter
avant de pouvoir bénéficier d'une
politique de prévention primaire des
risques professionnels qui prennent en
compte la pénibilité des postes et
l'usure professionnelle
les millions de salariés en télétravail
devront encore patienter pour bénéficier
d'un encadrement de l'organisation du
travail qui prévoit la prise en charge
intégrale des frais liés au travail à
distance par exemple
pour finir nous pensons que les chsct et
l instance indispensable qui permettait
d'avoir de véritables alertes et suivie
sur la prévention et la santé au travail
nous regrettons leur disparition les
sénatrices et sénateurs du groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologistes voteront donc contre cette
proposition de loi
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
dans la suite de la discussion la parole
est à mme adams au logo pour le groupe
union centriste pour six minutes
[Applaudissements]
c'est le président
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mais mesdames et messieurs le
rapporteur mes chers collègues
la proposition de loi visant à renforcer
la prévention en santé au travail n'est
pas un texte à destination exclusive des
professionnels des ressources humaines
ce texte ne concerne tous c'est un texte
de société la santé au travail dans sa
dimension de réparation comme dans sa
dimension de prévention est un enjeu
essentiel
confronté à des défis majeurs elle ne
doit pas rester en dessous des radars la
pénurie de professionnels de santé la
crise sanitaire inédite le développement
d'autres méthodes de travail comme le
télétravail les reconversions
professionnelles mais aussi la très
grande hétérogénéité du monde de
l'entreprise et de l'offre des services
de santé au travail ont amené les
partenaires sociaux à travailler
conjointement à ses sujets ils ont
conclu le 9 décembre dernier un accord
national interprofessionnel qui s'appuie
sur de récents travaux parlementaires en
particulier ceux de nos collègues pascal
grenier stéphane artano rares à porter
le texte législatif qui en a découlé a
été adopté par l'assemblée nationale le
17 février dernier modifié par le sénat
le 6 juillet
la difficulté pour la commission mixte
paritaire qui s'est réuni hier ne fut
pas de trouver un consensus sur les 38
articles resta en discussion la volonté
conjointe d'aboutir et hélas les sujets
maîtriser approfondie des apports des
deux chambres furent pris en compte dans
une synthèse heureusement conclusive
non la difficulté je pense fut pour nous
de regarder constamment comme objectif
de produire un texte utile
opérationnelle adaptée que la culture de
la prévention du risque puisse ainsi
diffusés y compris au sein des très
petites entreprises ne pas être vécues
comme punitive est d'autant moins
lorsque se profile dans certains
secteurs une réelle pénurie de main
d'oeuvre
la commission mixte paritaire a donc
validé à la majorité parfois à
l'unanimité souvent 32 propositions qui
propose temps particulier de considérer
pour le harcèlement sexuel au travail
les faits subis par la victime
indépendamment de l'intention de
l'agresseur de permettre aux entreprises
de moins de 50 salariés de définir une
liste d'actions de prévention des
risques et de protection dans leur dos
mon unique d'évaluation des risques
professionnels sans formalisme
supplémentaire de déployer un portail
numérique d'archivage et du r peuvent
selon des modalités et délais à définir
de prévoir un suivi post exposition pour
les travailleurs ayant fait l'objet
d'une exposition à des risques
particuliers de ne pas complexifier les
procédures d'agrément des services de
prévention et de santé au travail
d'organiser l'accès réciproque est
circonscrit à des données contenues dans
le dossier médical partagé et dossier
médical en santé au travail
toujours en veillant au strict respect
du secret médical et au recueil du
centre consentement libre et éclairé du
salarié de donner la possibilité aux
médecins du travail de délégués
l'animation et la coordination de la
cellule de prévention de la désinsertion
professionnelle
un membre de l'équipe pluridisciplinaire
qui agit sous sa responsabilité de
clarifier la terminologie employée dans
le cadre du suivi individuel du
travailleur et parlait plutôt de
consultation ou entretien à distance
plutôt que de téléconsultation relevant
de la télémédecine au sens du code de la
santé publique d'instaurer une visite
médicale de mi-carrière de préciser les
complémentarités entre suivi de santé en
ville et au travail
les deux spécialités médicales
connaissant la même situation de pénurie
le médecin d'aptitude restant bien le
médecin du travail spécialistes
irremplaçable de confirmer qu'une space
formation spécifique doit être dispensée
avant 2023 au futur infirmier de santé
au travail qui occupe un rôle de plus en
plus central au sein des services de
santé au travail de prévoir que les
médecins du travail puisse déléguer
l'animation et la coordination de
l'équipe pluridisciplinaire mais
toujours sous leur responsabilité
mes chers collègues en conclusion de ces
travaux je souhaite également souligner
l'intérêt qui a été porté au delà des
salariés aux chefs d'entreprise qui
notamment dans les tpe pme sont exposés
aux risques professionnels dans des
conditions souvent très proches de
celles de leurs salariés
c'est donc une belle avancée que leur
soit reconnue la possibilité d'accéder à
un suivi en santé au travail similaire à
celui dont bénéficient ces derniers le
sénat leur a ouvert cette voie même si
ce n'est pas un titre gratuit
je souhaite enfin veut dire qu'on
bien fut difficile l'exercice
d'organiser la montée en puissance de la
prévention en santé au travail partout
et pour tous sans alourdir la charge de
travail de ces professionnels de santé
de plus en plus rares nous avons refusé
d'acter le déclin d'une spécialité
médicale à part entière préférant
espérer en des mesures qui la rendrait
plus attractive souhaitons que le but
soit atteint qu'en particulier les
patrons de tpe pme ne se perdent pas
dans les acronymes barbares les anihiler
du erp les cnts télé sp sdis peste et
ses pommes dmp et des msp que chacun
employeurs et salariés trouvent là des
pistes de progrès gagnant gagnant des
outils pratiques qui permettent de
protéger ce bien unique et irremplaçable
qu'est la santé de nos collaborateurs
vous l'aurez compris les centristes
donneront à votre favorable merci chers
collègues à la suite de la discussion
générale la parole est à madame le au
héros pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste républicains pour six minutes
je crois
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur et madame les
rapporteurs chers collègues
la proposition de loi qui nous réunit
aujourd'hui à la transposition d'un
accord national interprofessionnel en
proposition de loi examinée par le
parlement pour renforcer la prévention
au travail de la preuve la promo la
prévention pardon en santé au travail
nous regrettons que les médecins du
travail n'ait pas été plus largement
associés à la concertation avec des
partenaires sociaux ils sont pourtant
bien placé pour évaluer la santé au
travail et agir à l'amélioration de la
santé et de la prévention au travail
faute d'un accord ambitieux et de ce
cadre contraint accentuée par
l'application stricte des articles 40 et
45 de la constitution nous n'obtenons au
final qu'une proposition de loi a minima
elle portait pour ambition la prévention
et la santé au travail
mais elle apporte en réalité des
confusions et un risque de rapport
déséquilibré entre les travailleurs et
des employeurs
si les versions sorties de l'assemblée
nationale et du sénat étaient
insatisfaisants nous ne constatons pas
d'amélioration significative du texte
dans la version issue de la commission
mixte paritaire
la version actuelle contient un risque
de dégradation de la protection des
salariés
le texte opère un véritable glissement
de la santé au travail vers des missions
de santé publique et de promotion de la
santé globale soit une dilution de la
mission de santé au travail au profit
d'une notion de santé en entreprise il
ya une véritable confusion entre la
santé au travail c'est-à-dire relative à
l'organisation du travail en matière de
prévention des risques primaire et la
santé individuelle des travailleurs
relatives au comportement vis-à-vis de
l'alcool par exemple du tabac de la
pratique sportive
pour autant la version issu de la cmp
supprime la disposition introduite par
le sénat précisant que le personnel de
santé au travail contribuent à la
sensibilisation aux violences conjugales
ou sexuelles le rapprochement entre la
vie professionnelle et personnelle de
salariés voulue dans ce texte ne
s'applique pas dans le cas des violences
intrafamiliales grande cause du
quinquennat pourtant nous regrettons
fortement que ce sujet soit passé à la
trappe de la cmp
la présente proposition de loi présente
un risque pour les travailleurs en
organisant la déresponsabilisation de
l'employeur en matière de sécurité et de
protection de la santé des salariés
l'instauration n'apas for prevention à
l'article 3 peut être perçue en réalité
comme un permis autorisant les
employeurs à se dégager de leurs
responsabilités en matière de sécurité
au motif qu'un travailleur a été
préalablement informés et formés
l'examen au sinaï en cmp n'a
malheureusement pas apporté de solution
à ce problème pointé par notre groupe
lors des débats au sénat par ailleurs
donner l'accès du dossier médical
partagé au médecin du travail représente
un danger pour la protection des
salariés
cet accès au dossier médical peut être
préjudiciable aux salariés en
particulier lors des visites d'embauché
ou de reprise de travail
surtout lorsqu'il ya une nécessité
d'adaptation à l'emploi
la proposition de loi n'apporte aucune
solution aux principales problèmes
relatifs à la médecine du travail qui
nous inquiète tous et qui continuera de
nous inquiéter
je veux parler de la pénurie de médecins
du travail pour faire face à cette
pénurie
il est proposé de recourir aux médecins
correspondants
cette solution n'est pas une solution
dans le contexte de désertification
médicale que connaît actuellement notre
pays
de même ces médecins correspondants
même avec deux années de formation
complémentaire ne pouvons pas faire de
prévention en entreprise
or c'est pourtant le rôle essentiel du
médecin du travail
toutefois les discussions entre les
députés des sénateurs et de gouvernement
ont permis quelques évolutions positives
des textes la première est de prendre en
compte aussi bien les agissements
sexistes que les propos ou comportements
à connotation sexuelle dans les
situations visé dans la définition du
harcèlement sexuel au travail la prise
en compte des faits subis par la victime
indépendamment de l'intention des
personnes concernées de les imposer
va dans ce sens les propositions que
nous avions formulées lors de l'examen
au sénat
par ailleurs nous saluons l'adoption
d'un amendement à l'article 2 terre pour
instaurer un suivi renforcé pour les
salariés ayant été exposés à des risques
particuliers pour leur santé ou leur
sécurité
de même la nouvelle version du texte
porte une vigilance particulière aux
nouvelles formes d'organisation du
travail et en particulier le télétravail
elle dispose que les services de
prévention et de santé au travail prête
une attention particulière à l'impact
que peut avoir le télétravail sur la
santé et la sécurité des travailleurs
dans le même sens
nous sommes également favorables au
rétablissement de la disposition retenu
par l'assemblée nationale qui consiste à
prévoir que le service de prévention et
de santé au travail devra être associé
aux futurs rendez-vous de liaison entre
l'employeur et le salarié en arrêt de
travail
cette présence permet de protéger de
salariés des éventuelles pressions de
l'employeur et d'éviter le tête à tête
salariés employeurs s'agissant de la
possibilité pour les infirmiers 10
pouces disposant de la qualification
nécessaire d'exercer en pratique avancée
en matière de prévention et de santé au
travail la disposition ne nous satisfait
pas totalement si elle permet en effet
de protéger les infirmiers qui exercent
sous la responsabilité du médecin du
travail
elle les empêche le plein exercice de la
pratique avancée et risque de
dévaloriser in fine et le métier
d'infirmier et cette spécialisation
cette proposition loi porteuse de grands
espoirs concernant la pénurie de
médecins de travail la prévention des
risques primaire les inégalités
territoriales n'apporte en réalité pas
de réponses concrètes aux difficultés
posées par l'exercice de la médecine du
travail
nous le regrettons et en conséquence le
groupe socialistes écologistes et
républicains ne soutiendra pas ce texte
merci chers collègues dans la suite de
discussions la parole et à monsieur
chassaing pour les replis indépendant
pour 4 minutes
monsieur le président monsieur ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
madame monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues notre assemblée examine à
présent les conclusions de la cmp sur
les dispositions de la proposition de
loi pour renforcer la prévention en
santé au travail
le groupe et indépendance félicite de
l'accord de smp cette proposition de loi
s'appuie sur plus de surplus de deux ans
de négociations avec les partenaires
sociaux aboutissants un accord signé le
18 décembre dernier
la cmp a trouvé un certain nombre
d'avancées apportées par le sénat en
première lecture et donc je fais ici
madame et monsieur le rapporteur pour
leur travail permettant d'améliorer le
texte je soutiens les mesures adoptées
visant à adapter les actions de
prévention aux entreprises de moins de
50 salariés ainsi que le dépôt du
document unique d'évaluation de
prévention des risques professionnels
sur un portail numérique pour garantir
sa conservation
je suis favorable à la valorisation du
rôle du médecin du travail du travail à
travers l'expérimentation d'une
extension de leur pouvoir de
prescription dans les limites des
missions de prévention dans le cadre de
la crise sanitaire les médecins du
travail ont déjà la possibilité de
prescrire des arrêts de travail
le texte étend cette possibilité à la
prescription des soins ou des examens
nécessaires à la prévention de
l'altération de l'état de santé des
salariés
autre avancée importante retenue par la
cmp
les salariés intérimaires pourront
bénéficier d'actions de prévention
collective près 3 millions de salariés
verront ainsi leur accès à la santé
renforcer le texte comfort comfort par
ailleurs le suivi de l'état de santé des
salariés des particuliers employeurs et
des chefs d'entreprise qui pourront
bénéficier du suivi assuré par le
service de prévention de santé
du travail auquel adhèrent leur
entreprise les récentes enquêtes
réalisées auprès des dirigeants de tpe
et pme témoigne d'une forte dégradation
détérioration de leur état de santé en
raison de la crise sanitaire avec des
risques particulièrement élevé de
burnout la proposition de loi améliorant
la coordination entre la médecine du
travail et la médecine de ville et
favorise la délégation de compétence aux
infirmiers en pratique avancée sous la
responsabilité du médecin la création de
médecins correspondants qui pourront se
former en médecine du travail
contribueront à renforcer les effectifs
du médecin du travail dans les
territoires sous dotées dans ces
territoires
la tendance à la désertification
médicale risque de s'aggraver dans les
années à venir avec le non
renouvellement des départs en retraite
près de 60 % de médecins du travail ont
plus de 55 ans actuellement il est donc
essentiel d'organiser une plus grande
fluidité des parcours entre la médecine
de ville et la médecine du travail est
de valoriser cette profession ce texte
propose des avancées
la commission des affaires sociales du
sénat y est largement contribué et notre
groupe se félicite du travail collégial
avec l'assemblée nationale dans le cadre
d'un cmp notre groupe est favorable à
cette réforme largement partagée avec
les partenaires sociaux
nous voterons donc en faveur des
conclusions de la cmp
merci chers collègues dans la suite de
la discussion la parole est à mal à me
poncet monge pour l'europe écologie
solidarité territoire pour 4 minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues lors de
l'examen du texte nous avions regretté
une occasion manquée de présenter un
projet de loi santé santé au travail
ambitieux plutôt qu'une transcription
incomplète de l'accord national
interprofessionnel de 2020 qui n'en
respecte même pas tous les équilibres et
ce au détriment des salariés
non seulement le texte n'est pas à la
hauteur des enjeux
mais poursuit la démédicalisation de la
santé au travail
il ne revient pas sur la dégradation des
services de santé au travail des duos
réformes antérieures et par certains de
ces dispositifs la grave comme il
n'écarte pas le risque d'échappement de
la responsabilité personnelle de
l'employeur
quant à ses obligations en termes de
santé sécurité pendant les débats les
écologistes ont porté une autre vision
du travail de la santé au travail en
intimant au parlement de se contraindre
à l'accord interprofessionnel signé par
quatre syndicats
la majorité présidentielle a dénié à
l'état et au parlement sa responsabilité
propre
quant à la santé au travail et puis
beaucoup de nos propositions ont été
rejetées
y compris celles qu construite avec les
professionnels et les syndicats dont
certains
certains syndicats avaient pourtant
signé la nuit le résultat est donc
encore aggravée au sortir de la
commission mixte paritaire
nous avions rappelé que la santé la
sécurité des salariés n'était pas
obsolète optionnel le texte prévoit
toujours une offre socle est
complémentaire au sein des services de
santé au travail des gens qui n'ont pas
de temps médical suffisant nous avions
réaffirmé la responsabilité personnelle
de l'employeur en matière de santé et
sécurité
car si le pouvoir d'organisation n'est
pas partagée alors la responsabilité ne
saurait l'être
le texte consacre des dispositifs qui la
relativise nous voulions mettre en
lumière les risques psychosociaux
deuxième cause d'arrêts de travail en
mai 2020 le texte ne saisit pas
l'occasion d'en faire progresser la
prise en compte nous avions défendu les
droits des salariés de leurs instances
notamment en portant la vie du cs
le duo est comme de protection des
données personnelles de santé
le texte confirme l'accès au dossier
médical partagé aux professionnels ds pc
est resté et balaye le renforcement du
consentement du salarié pourtant adopté
en commission au sénat
nous avions combattu les dispositifs
actes en l'effacement des médecins du
travail et dépréciant leur spécialité le
texte prévoit le recours à des médecins
devine correspondant pour le suivi des
salariés
la cmp a rétabli et ça cela est très
grave nous ce canton le souligner a
rétabli la possibilité pour le médecin
du travail de délégués l'animation et la
coordination de l'équipe
pluridisciplinaire supprimée en
commission au sénat
et enfin nous avions proposé un grade de
master 2 pour le diplôme d'infirmier en
santé au travail et son statut de
salarié protégé le texte recul
supprimant la mention même d'une
formation universitaire dédié
maigre consolation dans cet exercice
décidément préoccupant pour quiconque
est attaché à la santé au travail
le seul amendement que nous avions fait
adopter en commission sociale au sénat
savoir le remplacement dans le code du
travail de la notion de qualité de vie
au travail par celle de la qualité de
vie et des conditions de travail a été
maintenue les écologistes donc vous
l'avez compris votre rencontre et
réaffirme la nécessité d'une réforme
ambitieuse de la santé au travail
merci chers collègues dans la suite de
la discussion la parole à monsieur biya
qu pour le groupe r d est ce pour quatre
minutes
monsieur le président ce ministre madame
monsieur le rapporteur chers collègues
la crise sanitaire que nous traversons
depuis plus d'un an nous rappelle
combien de la santé au travail a
légitimement sa place au sein de notre
politique de santé publique
mais nombreuses sont les études mettant
en évidence les limites de
l'organisation des services médicaux du
travail je pense notamment au rapport
d'information publié il ya deux ans déjà
par les deux rapporteurs pascale gruny
et stéphane artano que je salue les deux
dernières grandes réformes de la santé
au travail à 2011 et 2016 recherches
rapporté certaines améliorations mais
force est de reconnaître qui est
aujourd'hui nécessaire qu'elle repose
davantage sur une logique de prévention
et non plus seulement sur des mécanismes
de réparation des atteintes à la santé
des travailleurs
mieux vaut prévenir que guérir ou si
vous préférez
comme le disait le philosophe anglais
john locke au xviie siècle
si l'on ne réussit pas prévenir le mal
il ne peut être guérie sans beaucoup de
difficultés comme je vous ai déjà dit
lors de l'examen de la proposition de
leur sénat le 16 juillet dernier ici
même
une des particularités de ce texte qu'il
est issu de l'accord national
interprofessionnel du 9 décembre 2020
qui est et signait rappelons le à la
quasi totalité des organisations
syndicales sauf une
sur le fond je tiens à saluer la qualité
du travail effectué par nos deux
assemblées et l'accord trouvé en
commission mixte paritaire
il faut aussi souligner que si la cmp
est parvenu à un accord
elle a retenu de nombreuses dispositions
adoptées par le sénat
preuve que nos deux assemblées ça va
s'entendre sur un sujet essentiel pour
la vie de nos concitoyens et de nos
travailleurs pour ma part évidemment je
regrette qu'aucun de mes amendements ont
été adoptés et notamment celui sur la
téléconsultation ou encore pour une
meilleure prise en compte la
représentation des salariés des
entreprises petites et moyennes pourquoi
été dit par les orateurs précédents
mais je venais rapidement sur les points
qui constituent les avancées comme
l'expérimentation du droit de
prescription du médecin du travail cher
à notre collègue rapporteur stéphane
artano selon ses propres termes c'est à
la fois une réponse au défi de la
démographie médicale mais aussi
l'opportunité de décloisonner médecine
de ville et médecine du travail dans le
même effort de cohérence en santé
publique
la recherche d'une homogénéisation des
services de la prévention santé autour
du socle commun de prestations est un
progrès attendu et nécessaire
elle se concrétise grâce au document
unique d'évaluation et de prévention des
risques professionnels
la scène fait conserve d'ailleurs
l'obligation de déposer dématérialisée
du début sur un portail numérique géré
par l'oreillette aux employeurs ainsi
que l'expérimentation d'actions de
prévention collective destinée aux
salariés intérimaires et l'autre
également l'adaptation aux entreprises
de moins de 50 salariés des exigences en
matière d'actions de prévention et de
protection découlant de l'élaboration du
document unique
considérant que ce texte est une avancée
même s'il n'est pas parfait et qu'il
donne des moyens à la médecine du
travail de s'ouvrir une approche
pluridisciplinaire face aux nouvelles
formes de travail nos évolutions vers
les chevaux sera en faveur de ce texte
merci chers collègues dans la suite et
la fin de la discussion générale la
porte et monsieur riche et pardon madame
madame tout à fait excuser moi madame
riches et pour les républicains
pardon c'est pas grave
non monsieur le président monsieur
ministre madame la présidente de la
commission d'amm la rapporteure monsieur
le rapporteur
mes chers collègues nous achevons cet
après midi l'examen d'un texte dont le
mûrissement a été long sans doute
davantage qu'à l'accoutumée la
proposition de loi que nous nous
apprêtons à adopter définitivement est
en effet le fruit de riches mois de
travail
d'abord syndical puis parlementaire pour
répondre aux défis actuels en matière de
santé au travail et partenaires sociaux
sont parvenus à un accord national
interprofessionnel le 9 décembre dernier
puis dans un format peu commun
le parlement était saisi de ce texte
d'origine syndicale
l'exercice n'est pas toujours simple
sans rien renier de notre pouvoir
souverain de voter la loi
il nous a fallu trouver un équilibre qui
respecte la volonté des organisations
professionnelles
je crois que nous y sommes arrivés et je
tiens à saluer à cette tribune avec
force le travail de fond accompli par
nos deux rapporteurs pascale gruny et
stéphane artano le texte qui entrera
bientôt dans le marbre de notre droit
apporte des réponses circonstanciées à
des problèmes que la crise sanitaire a
contribué à mettre en lumière en
renforçant la prévention dans le milieu
professionnel
les entreprises seront demain plus à
même de détecter en amont des
pathologies qui nécessitent une prise en
charge rapide il convenait pour cela de
muscler certains dispositifs d'en
rationaliser d'autres voire d'en créer
de nouveaux c'est ainsi que le document
unique d'évaluation des risques
professionnels du herd deviendra bientôt
la pierre angulaire la référence
stratégique permettant de recenser les
risques internes à l'entreprise et les
actions que celle ci doit mettre en
oeuvre pour y pallier avec cette loi
la médecine du travail et médecine de
ville seront un peu moins être close
cloisonné
un peu plus complémentaire grâce
notamment à l'ouverture facilité d accès
entre dossier médical partagé dossier
médical en santé au travail
je tiens à souligner également le
travail de rationalisation souhaitée par
l'ani est inscrit dans la loi dans les
différentes offres de services proposés
par les services de prévention et de
soutien au travail
les critiques sur l'hétérogénéité de ces
offres était récurrente et je crois que
la procédure de certification que nous
allons voter permettra d'y mettre bon
ordre
de même que la distinction entre offres
socle et offre complémentaire
enfin cette proposition de loi va
permettre à de nouveaux publics comme
les personnes en situation de handicap
de bénéficier d'une couverture préventif
complète ce qui n'est au fond qu'une
mesure de bon sens mes chers collègues
le dialogue parlementaire a porté ses
fruits
et je me réjouis du maintien dans le
texte élaboré par la commission mixte
paritaire de nombreuses dispositions
introduites à l'initiative de notre
assemblée
c'est le cas tout d'abord concernant l'
équilibre trouvé entre la nécessaire
exigences de prévention de la santé au
travail et la volonté de ne pas alourdir
les contraintes pesant sur les très
petites entreprises
notre commission des affaires sociales a
ainsi prévu que les entreprises de moins
de 50 salariés pourraient définir leurs
actions de prévention sans se voir
imposer le formalisme d'un programme
annuel de prévention c'est une rédaction
de compromis qui a une fille n'ait été
retenu qui lisent à garantir que les
actions de prévention et de protection
que les entreprises de moins de 50
salariés doivent définir seront
obligatoirement listées dans ledit verte
la cmp a par ailleurs maintenu
l'ouverture de l'offre socle de services
fournis par les sp est et aux
travailleurs indépendants que le sénat
va introduit en première lecture
notre assemblée a enrichi sur de
nombreux autres points
le texte de l'ani examiné préalablement
à l'assemblée nationale nous avons ainsi
souhaité renforcer l' approche
préventive de la santé au travail
grâce à la prise en compte des
situations de poly exposition pour les
travailleurs exposés à des risques
chimiques définir plus précisément
l'offre
socle de services délivrés par les sp
est et enrichir les dispositions
concernant la certification et la
tarification des mesures mises en place
par les services de prévention ou encore
mieux inclure les questions de
harcèlement sexuel dans les politiques
de prévention
je pourrais également cité le compromis
trouvé avec nos collègues députés
concernant l'intégration du passeport
prévention passeport formation lorsque
les salariés disposent d'un tel document
mais aussi l'amélioration du dispositif
prévu par là ni de visites de mi
carrière
je tiens enfin souligné que le sénat en
commission mixte paritaire a obtenu
l'inscription en dur si j'ose dire des
dispositions de regroupement d arak au
sein des ânes acte que le gouvernement
souhaitait voir prise par ordonnance
mes chers collègues vous le constatez
beaucoup de mesures adoptées par notre
assemblée figurent dans le texte final
et c'est une réalité dont nous pouvons
nous réjouir dans l'intérêt des salariés
et des entreprises
je souhaite donc que les dispositions
réglementaires puissent être prises
rapidement afin d'assurer une couverture
préventive optimale à tous les employés
de notre pays
ce texte est une belle réalisation de ce
que la démocratie sociale peut produire
et c'est bien naturellement que le
groupe ait l'air le votera je vous
remercie
merci madame riches merci bien la
discussion générale est close je
rappelle qu'en application de l'article
42 alinéa 12 du règlement aucun
amendement n'est recevable sauf accord
du gouvernement le sénat étant appelés à
se prononcer avant l'assemblée nationale
il statue sur les éventuels amendements
puis par un seul vote sur l'ensemble du
texte
nous passons la présentation les
amendements du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
messieurs les sénateurs se sera retirée
en cours si vous permettez monsieur le
président je simplement préciserai que
les trois amendements qui vous sont
proposés ci sont à un simple porte et
rédactionnelles aux articles 5 9 et 12
je vous invite à aller voter
merci monsieur le rapporteur
oui s'agit simplement d'un moment de
pure coordination logistique donc un
avis favorable d'ensemble merci donc je
vais mettre aux voix l'ensemble de la
proposition de loi dans la rédaction
résultant du texte élaboré par la
commission mixte paritaire modifié par
les amendements précédemment adoptée par
le sénat
je fait voter d'abord pas sur les
amendements pardon sur le premier
amendement l'amendement 1 avec un des
favoris de la commission qui et pour qui
est content qui s'abstient il est adopté
même vote pour le 2 mai mme vote et
adoptée mais votre 3 il est adopté
donc je mets aux voix l'ensemble des
propositions de loi dans la rédaction
résultant du texte élaboré par la
commission mixte paritaire
modifié par les amendements du
gouvernement entier pour qui et contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas et y est
adopté par la proposition de loi est
adopté
[Musique]